sam i suppose we could call this a bit
of a rethink couldn't we from from the
chancellor there was a lot of pressure
on him
uh to do so but already quick out of the
block after that announcement we've had
comments from the cbi
and indeed the opposition saying that
all this tooing and throwing
is just confusing for everybody well
rishi sunak wouldn't call it a u-turn he
wouldn't call it
a rethinking of his decision to close
the furlough scheme
but enough in an effect in a targeted
way that's exactly
uh what's happened uh today two weeks
ago he was going to move
all of uh businesses onto a much less
generous scheme
called the job support scheme but today
as the latest coronavirus figures from
yesterday
showed 17 000 new cases and the prospect
of lockdowns now
in the north east and northwest being
announced on monday
government has to act and has to act
much more generously
than it had been planning even just a
week or two
ago and that will mean two things first
of all
that for businesses that are forced to
close um
either on monday or have already been
forced to shut
workers will be able to claim two-thirds
of salary and
employers will be compensated for that
and also there's this more
uh generous grant scheme as well
and i think this is uh something as i
say that rishi sunak wasn't particularly
keen to do
but it is an important moment i do think
that it is important that it is less
generous than the original furlough
scheme
which offered eighty percent of salary
somewhere up to about thirty thousand
pounds this
uh takes you down to around twenty five
thousand uh
or so um but the biggest question of
course
will be if you're doing this because
you're about to close a whole load of
businesses down what businesses are you
thinking of shutting down and as you
heard in the interview that
rishi sunat just did he wasn't prepared
to say
it does sound all but certain as if the
government are going to announce
wholesale closures of industries
possibly the hospitality industry in the
north of england parts of the north of
england
on monday but where for how long and how
widespread the restrictions we've just
got no idea
even though members of sage and
ministers
say that um just four or five days is
that
could be the difference between uh
surviving the second spike and disaster
in intensive care units around the
country